this u.s border facility appears more
like an overcrowded daycare center
it's only supposed to hold 250 people
overall there are more than 4 thousand
including 3 400 children
smuggled to the u.s border alone i'm a
father
how do you i don't want to see that as a
border patrol agent i didn't sign up for
this
border patrol isn't supposed to detain
children for more than three days
but with no space available at longer
term facilities
most have weighted well beyond the legal
limit
president joe biden has been criticized
for his lack of transparency to the
process
this is the first time journalists have
been allowed inside the facility since
he took office
in 2018 former president donald trump
was criticized for separating migrant
children from their families
a tough stance on immigration was a key
plank in his make america great again
agenda
we're starting to see younger and
younger kids being brought over by their
sponsors by relatives by grandparents
whoever it is in the family that is
actually asking for these kids and
paying the fees to smuggle these kids
into the country
and more are coming
people eat one day and not the other
that's the way things are in our country
yes people are desperate several hundred
hondurans
set off on tuesday hoping to reach the
united states
of course i'm afraid they say they're
waiting for us with tear gas at the u.s
border but what are we going to do we
have to suffer
to enjoy later on
and harrowing stories of suffering
arrive every day
about a month and a half ago i was back
here talking to one of the little girls
you know and and i told the the
congressional delegation this
the same thing right we were gonna send
her to the hospital
and as i got close to her i noticed that
she couldn't speak and i asked the
medical staff what happened
and she's the reason she was going to
the hospital because she had gotten gang
raped
and the reason that she couldn't speak
was because she had lost her voice in
the process while she was getting raped
pressure is mounting on biden to handle
a fast spiraling situation
decisions that will have lifelong
implications for these young ones who've
already made the journey
leah harding al jazeera